[Musik]
im Privatjet zur Schicht es ist kurz vor
acht Alexandre coucher und fünf weitere
Ärzte fliegen heute von Dijon nach Nivea
in die französische Provinz das
Kreiskrankenhaus hat sie zur Hilfe
gerufen es fehlt Personal wie fast
überall auf dem Land
[Musik]
es ist ein grundsätzliches Problem und
sehr komplex es reicht nicht einfach nur
mehr Ärzte auszubilden man muss Anreize
schaffen damit die dann in Städte Wiener
Wert ziehen
der mittelalterliche Ort am Ufer der
Loire scheint auf den ersten Blick
attraktiv doch seine Lage fern jeder
Großstadt schreckt viele ab auch
Alexandre Kuschel kann sich nicht
vorstellen hierher zu ziehen regelmäßig
auszuhelfen hingegen schon dank Flug und
Shuttle braucht er nur eine gute halbe
Stunde für die Anreise
ich komme frisch an und bin gleich
bereit besser als wenn ich drei Stunden
im Auto gefahren wäre oder zweieinhalb
Stunden Zug so bin ich leistungsfähiger
finanziert wird die Luftbrücke von der
Klinik fünfeinhalb tausend Euro hin und
zurück acht Ärzte können so eingeflogen
werden hallo Muriel wie geht es dir
auch sie könnte gut Unterstützung
brauchen Sie lieber Diego gay ist
freiberufliche Krankenschwester seit dem
plötzlichen Tod des dorfarztes vor zwei
Jahren hat sie deutlich mehr zu tun und
mehr Verantwortung
das ist super dein Sauerstoff ist 90
Prozent oh so gut war es nie
wir dürfen sie bei einem ihrer täglichen
Hausbesuche begleiten die Patientin
leidet unter mehreren Krankheiten ein
Teil der Lunge fehlt dass sie keinen
Arzt mehr in Ihrer Nähe hat beunruhigt
sie sehr wenn es ihr schlecht geht ruft
sie den Krankenwagen
die Patienten überlaufen die Stationen
mit Krankheiten die eigentlich kein
Notfall sind
beim kleinsten Unfall der kleinsten
Wunde gehen sie dorthin weil sie keinen
Arzt erreichen
wir haben keine andere Wahl in den
ländlichen Regionen Frankreichs sind
viele Praxen völlig überlastet mit
finanziellen Zuschüssen versucht das
Ministerium Mediziner für
versorgte Regionen zu gewinnen der
Erfolg ist mäßig was
ich finde man sollte Studenten
verpflichten einige Zeit auch in kleine
Dörfer zu gehen oder vielleicht auch
nach dem Studium für ein oder zwei Jahre
eine Idee die immer wieder diskutiert
aber nicht durchgesetzt wird
zurück in Nivea auch hier im Krankenhaus
fehlt es ein Nachwuchs zwar wurde der
Zugang zum Studium vereinfacht ein
Effekt ist aber noch nicht zu spüren
vielleicht in ein paar Jahren
eure Untersuchung ist gut verlaufen geht
es ihnen gut ich habe gesehen sie haben
ja schon einige hinter sich sie sind
daran gewöhnt ja das bin ich Alexandra
der eingeflogene Arzt muss ich immer
wieder neu in die Akten einlesen er ist
spezialisiert auf Nuklearmedizin die z.B
Veränderungen in Organen erkennen kann
hochmoderne Geräte hat die Leiterin die
kurz vor ihrer Rente steht angeschafft
um eine Nachfolger anzulocken doch
keiner will auch nicht die Studenten die
bei ihr Station machen
es ist nicht einfach nach zehn Jahren
Studium alles zu verlassen um dann in
einer Region zu leben die er nicht nur
medizinisch attraktiv sein muss sondern
für das gesamte Lebensumfeld
die Regierung hat die Notlage vernommen
eine landesweite Lösung gibt es jedoch
nicht ohne das freiwillige Engagement
der Ärzte aus anderen Regionen müsste
die Station in Nivea schließen
es handelt sich um eine Notlösung um
einem drängenden Problem beizukommen
der Ärzte Mangel ist absolut kritisch
und wenn man die CO2-Bilanz berechnet
dann muss man auch mit bedenken dass die
Patienten zu uns reisen müssten wenn wir
Ärzte nicht nach Nivea kämen
[Musik]
hier treffen wir die Krankenschwester
Sylvie bei wieder sie verteilt Plakate
und Flyer hat einen Verein gegründet um
einen neuen Hausarzt anzuwerben
ich würde mich freuen wenn du das in
deinem Schaufenster aufhängen könntest
danke
vielleicht kommt ein Arzt oder eine
Ärztin auf Durchreise vorbei im Café de
la place geben Sie die Hoffnung nicht
auf
wir wissen nicht mehr weiter und wohin
wir gehen sollen deshalb unterstützen
wir die Initiative
das sei neben der medizinischen
Versorgung insgesamt wichtig für den
Standort die Läden die Wirtschaft
erklärt uns die Bürgermeisterin nicht
nur 2000 Patienten hat der Dorfarzt
hinterlassen sondern auch diese Praxis
mitsamt der Einrichtung wurde sie nun
von der Gemeinde gekauft damit die neue
oder der neue sofort loslegen kann
im Rahmen eines kommunalen
gesundheitsplans werden wir ihm einige
Monatsmieten erlassen sowohl für die
Arztpraxis als auch für ihn persönlich
für die Unterkunft darüber hinaus helfen
wir auch bei der Eingewöhnung hier in
unserer Gegend
doch in Frankreich darf jeder Arzt
selbst entscheiden wo er seine Praxis
eröffnet das erschwert die Suche
und so kämpft sie wie bei jiguel weiter
unermüdlich sie nimmt uns noch ein
kurzes Stück mit auf ihre Abendrunde
meine Tage sind ganz schön vollgepackt
ich stehe früh auf und komme spät abends
nach Hause nachmittags habe ich eine
kurze Pause die ich nutze um Patienten
anzurufen
der Druck werde immer größer erzählt sie
noch die Verzweiflung der Patienten auch
wird Zeit dass er einfliegt der
supermediziner in ihre Gemeinde mitten
in Frankreich
[Musik]